okay i got a very very important
question via voicemail
this is a practical question about
long voting lines for november take a
listen to this
very important to know the answer hey
david i just have a question
uh is it true that if you are in line to
vote
on voting day or on election day that
you have to legally be allowed to vote
so
you know even if the line is two miles
long as long as you're standing in it
before the polls close are you
legally able to vote that's what i'm
wondering about thank you
okay very important question legally
speaking
if you are in line to vote by the time
the polls close
you must be legally allowed to vote the
way it's supposed to work is
if polls close at 8 o'clock at 8 o'clock
someone a poll worker is supposed to go
to the end
of the line and sort of be a placeholder
for the end of the line
if you are in front of the poll worker
you must be allowed to vote whether it
takes five minutes or five hours or five
days because you were in line while the
polls were
open that's the rule you have to get to
the polls before they close
if you try to get in line after the
polls have closed the poll worker would
say
this is the end of the line the polls
are now closed you
you you're not going to be allowed to
vote that's the way it's supposed to
work
you can weaponize that you could
hypothetically if you were you know a
bad actor
you could try to disproportionately
send people to try to spread
disinformation
and usher people in line away by saying
the polls have already closed you're not
going to be allowed to vote you could
focus that
effort in democratic precincts for
example where you're not looking
specifically at who's in line but you're
like
okay this precinct has more democrats
this precinct has more republicans let's
go to the democratic precinct
and try to get people to go home and say
the polls have closed you're not going
to be allowed to vote you could do that
and so the point is yes if you're in
line before the polls close
you must be allowed to vote there may be
dirty tricks they may pull stuff don't
fall for it
we've got a great bonus show for you
today a florida sheriff is telling his
deputies not to wear
masks if you can imagine a woman
who says she has coronavirus is being
evicted
and we have new polling from the senate
race in massachusetts between incumbent
ed markey and challenger joe kennedy
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show